what up reject nation look at us we're
back with brooklyn nine-nine and you're
our first mikey experiment well not our first
we actually have like a gazillion microphones
we've got so much and we just can't see so much
sound can't seem to figure it out we'll get it
yeah we have though the weirdest my dream
is consistent sound for youtube channel
my dream someday is to take an entire day just
to figure out the sounds once and for all yeah
you have so many things on the walls tears
like that this is a sound it's all really good
you're our trial for this one to see how
this one goes unfortunately the best way
to run these tests is to see what it's like
when we do a full recording yeah we're back
at it now that the new place is here this
is episode something another thing 11 so
if you guys leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated let us know if this sounds all
right it's a little much we're probably just going
to switch to headphones like my brother doesn't
have a little earpiece here it's probably the most
efficient way to do it honestly because we usually
have two to three people on camera with us that's
why it's a little bit more complicated i'm also
like i don't want this like giant-ass pole and
mike in the thumbnails i really care about that
i'm pretty particular about the thumbnails
anywho it's a lot of crap i just told you
guys subscribe and click that bell and also um
yeah you can check us on patreon that'd be very
much appreciated thanks to the boys at prepper
for helping us out of these down let's get to it
are you eating an italian sub for breakfast i
am but amy said i should eat more veggies so
i got extra pepperoncinis smort love a good
pepperoni oh no you need to watch yourself
i'm sorry cop all right are you going to
arrest me for dancing you call that dancing
is dancing oh please what
is happening let's do this
dancing over situation diffused
all right you guys are adorable tell me everything
the doctor says about your uterine climate
and also that gross big news is this something
other people would keep private big time we're
trying to have a baby oh wow that is awesome
that's big news charles i thought you were sterile
i distinctly remember you using the phrase
shooting dust yes oh yes i imagined that
yeah i still don't know why
you dove in crotch first
first stephen we're gonna fill out
form 38e dash j1 stating non-compliance
we send it to the da but do they process it
right away no because they're overwhelmed
so your court date won't be set for six or
eight weeks and even then you're gonna have
to block out the whole day because they don't
give you a specific time no no it's a window
i thought we were gonna try to scare
him there's nothing scarier than the
realities of the municipal court system
now come on let's get back in there and
tell them about how bad the website is look
i'll talk about the turnout i was hoping for
maybe i should've offered free strudel
then at least scully would've come
there's free strudel i'm gonna come at you
and you're gonna take me down you better
impress me if you want that recommendation
to be good i'm gonna try sarge here we go
me a wowie
and that's what you get for lying about
free strudel karma's a [__] oh god
who's catherine
your ex-wife is here that one more oh there's
no male thing but it's my sperm how did you even
find out i wanted it because it counts under my
name storage facility called me saying that you
were looking to make a withdrawal so i went ahead
and withdrew it for you i have all of your sperm
oh my god oh hey charles i'll never have a baby
with you because i don't love you and a child's
not gonna fix that oof when we started doing the
silly voice i thought it was gonna be more fun
i hit some dumb ass with my car now he's
suing me what i want is for you to use your
badge and your gun to intimidate him into
dropping the case i'm gonna take your sperm
and i'm gonna dump it into the east river please
don't do that there will never be the possibility
of a little pie-faced charles boyle jr proud of
it it's me what a terrible person the sperm is her
legal possession it also says that she and i quote
owns your dignity you initialed right next to that
total disaster i'll never be happy in my
life why are you smiling because this is
exactly what we've trained for it's a hostage
situation and we're gonna bring your boys home
here's what we know about eleanor
oh my good wedding day i should have
known it was a mistake when she said
i suppose instead of i do all right
hey sergeant how are you well my
baby cries at the side of my face now
if it helps i brought you
some soothing ginger tea don't
repair the place where my nose
came off my skull i don't know
but it's supposed to have healing vapors so
try inhaling it thank you oh no no no no oh
no wow
do you threaten that nine-year-old man
for me yet but the guy you hit was 90.
yeah and you would know that if you had talked
to him which obviously you did not so goodbye
we need proof of life i'd be happy to dump one
of the containers out of the window no no don't
do that please don't dump my sperm on us hello
ma'am gina take a statement yes thank you i'm
gonna get this guy to admit to crimes he hasn't
even committed no that would be a huge problem
the guy wanted to talk to a real person not a
cop that's why he asked for me actually i asked
for you because we went to high school together
what stephen henderson we had a bunch of classes
together no no eleanor jake charles okay you just
said your own name this is the only one okay so
as soon as she comes back in here i'm gonna
grab that cup right out of her hands and
run like hell you think that'll work i
don't just think it will i know it might
there are two real containers one is in a safe
location and this is the other one or rather
it was the other one no
what are you doing i'm sorry
but i don't have a choice jake
i'm gonna go bully an old priest so i can get
my sperms back priest friend no no carl what
are you doing no no no no no not the keys no oh
i should have known you're a hugger not a shaker
rejected i've never been rejected from anything
me neither did you say rejected or ejected i've
been rejected a lot my application was so
good you know what i've also been ejected
how could you excuse me it's the only explanation
you're mad that i broke your face and
i burned your whole body well grow up
i have a roth i.r.a i eat wheat toast you grow
up here's the letter that i sent amy santiago is
one of the finest detectives in my precinct nay
the entire nypd yeah i even used the word nay
you would question my integrity is solid
oh oh no oh no i gotta sneeze no no no
there's gonna be lots of blood
here quick hand me those keys
what will you give me for them
a dollar for soda mine are all wet
yes obviously i'll give you that
soda only cost 75 cents you fool see
you later sucka didn't even give him
stay straight you interrupted the song for
that yeah yep she came up onto the sidewalk
and fractured my hip you were a pedestrian are you
totally a pedestrian if you're sitting on a bench
yawns are coming
hi there i'm jake this is my best friend
charles he's trying to have a baby you get it
come here you charles i know you're
mad but you have to talk to me funny
how getting taste in the back can break your heart
i really wanted to be a papa and you ruined it you
pop blocked me i know i have a biological father
and he's a nightmare he never played catch
with me he never taught me how to ride a bike
i had to learn how to shave from watching home
alone makes sense it's like die hard for kids
oh my god it is but i do know that you're gonna
be a great dad with or without your boy oil no
not gonna say it but you will adopt my guy adopt i
sent the recommendation letter to the wrong place
i thought you were applying to be a mentor not
a mentee you thought i wanted to be a sam not a
sam are you insane well you should be a sam no
i should be a sam you are ready to be teaching
others i made a call you're going to be a mentor
oh my god i'm so sorry for ever questioning your
integrity thank you no no no don't stand back
look i'm still very scared of you i got stephen
to talk yeah it's fantastic how did you do it did
you finally show him the municipal court website
i found something we bonded
over she didn't even know who i
was and we were good friends on more than one
occasion she's called me gina that's her own
i'm in love and i'm going to be a dad and
there's nothing you could do to stop me
so goodbye forever oh and one more thing tell
hercules i'll see you about spin class on sunday
now goodbye yeah we were looking
at possible donors on the way over
yeah yeah yeah check out this guy i like
him he went to yale oh wait that says yeel
university swipe him off this is fun that's
weird that guy kind of looks like my dad
wait a minute oh my god no you cannot use
his sperm my son would be your brother
oh it was eleanor all along good shiz how long
were you waiting for that one john where sorry
how long were you waiting for that one i was
anticipating the right opportunity but it never
arose within the plot of the episode there was no
big reveal involving eleanor so i still thought it
was fun he was pretty funny thank you that's funny
you did a funny joke thanks man funny is good
that's uh welcome to asmr standard
comedy asmr what's the deal with this
let me get my hot breath in
there some some good mouth clicks
all right guys this is the episode where you
whip out podcast mike's for this is the one this
is brooklyn nine now this is the one where we're
gonna we're gonna talk forever warren's warren's
microphones up close to your face most pro
sounding brooklyn nine-nine discussion impossible
that was really fun you know i've thought
about adopting i've always wanted to adopt
instead you know like even though they don't
end on adopting i like that message at the
end that a dad comes in all form shapes and
sizes and it doesn't have to be just you know
from your own sperm dna itself i feel there's
a different association to be had with it
however i do think that a lot of times you know
like my people have shitty dads and they find a
father figure instead and that could be the one
you called that i have a i mean i don't want him
to be the one to i don't want to just put his
personal life out there but i do know someone
whose dad abandoned them and then he has a someone
who their the mother his mother started dating
like the boyfriend and been the boyfriend for
many many many years and he calls him dad instead
and uh yeah so i i do like the way this this all
ended ultimately yeah like katherine hahn also
just played villain and wasn't like funny villain
she was legit like a frustrating [__] yeah she
wasn't funny yeah no totally she felt very real
and i thought catherine oh he's gonna be like a
funny quirky villain and no no you seem like a
pretty pretty glass she knew that to make the
joke funnier it was for her to not play it funny
and then to let the other things like the the
uh reveals about the whole uh the how it just
kept escalating with the person she hit how it
just kept getting compoundingly worse and the more
it got closer to actually seeing the guy uh it was
funnier just because of how straightforward she
was in the beginning about the whole situation so
i think that uh some some solid solid comedy right
there so some good physical comment there's a lot
of physical comedy this episode mm-hmm a lot a lot
john why don't you talk about the physical comedy
yeah john yeah through the the bald either
i'll find different ways to let you know
i'm segueing you gotcha instead of being
like hey look look at me the baton here no
i thought there's a lot of really fun physical
comedy especially obviously with amy and terry
and uh your audio sounds so much better than
mine why is that i'm not sure this is crazy it's
[__] john's favoriting himself no that sounds
better now yeah it's just about the angle and the
proximity to your mouth god damn it it's okay it's
working progress uh yeah yeah i enjoyed the uh the
terry and uh uh amy storyline of uh you know yeah
him being increasingly afraid of her and him inc
undergoing increasing levels of pain and
anguish and justice league the way that she uh
that paid off and two yeah all the physical
like sight gags and stuff about like this
this this priest scenario speaking of psychics
you guys clearly know what this looked like
uh make yours make your pervy jokes people
i was gonna say why wha what do you mean oh
oh like a big uh lolly like a big popsicle yeah
mm-hmm because big black pops it's almost summer
time yeah get your charcoal popsicle going
i didn't know terry crews was in this video
hey that's right he is in in more ways than than
one because there's two anyway there's a lot of
good physical comedy in this episode and a lot
i don't know i thought all the plot lines had
uh had like obviously like the charles and and
uh and jake is the center piece and is the most
engaging but i loved watching yes terry
become more and more frightened of amy and
then holt doing his dancing and then later on
the whole bit with the interrogation and gina
talking to this guy and then finally that being
this catapult for rosa to identify with how much
they both get aggravated by her yeah uh yeah
they're really fun a lot of really fun games
and a lot of really fun even just like
with the physical timing of things like
scully showing up out of nowhere when
terry mentions strudel just like little
little things like that we're just like so
perfectly timed or uh even the bit with skully and
the uh hitchcock in the garage and the dollar and
the soda yeah there's like so many great little
back and forth quippy bits and things very true
yeah and uh i liked what everybody had to learn
this time but i'm glad i'm so i'm sad and i'm
glad i'm sad we didn't get to see the municipal
court website and just how nightmarish those pull
down menus are because it always mystifies me how
we live in a time and place especially in the
greatest country on earth these united states
of america like all the greatest yeah yeah but yet
all the like state and government technology sucks
it's like these websites don't work and like
you know even like basic things like wi-fi when
you got to go to a place like that it's like
just slow and it doesn't work and you're like
why why do we keep getting told we're in the most
state-of-the-art place in the world and we can't
get any of this [__] right you know because
it's not it's not gonna i'm not gonna go off on a
on a rant about capitalism now hey capitalism
is good oh sure depending on how you use it sure
maybe it's what's built this country it is
it is no there's a lot of corruption in capitalism
if you use capitalism properly it could be good
for a time what are you talking about what are you
thinking about i'm thinking of like bare minimum
capitalism minim mid-stage early stage capitalism
perhaps yeah like starting up a youtube channel
and deciding to make your living off of it is
a form of capitalism sure yeah that's not bad
no a lot of people who do it if you're watching
this you're supporting everyone whoever does it
no it's not that but it's it's it's a part
of a larger ecosystem of of interconnected
things that all are subject to the tenets
of capitalism those of which are debatable
yeah it's what it's about what
capitalism does to our human instincts
more so than this i think the the greedy
part of capitalism is the bad part
and it incentivizes that greed though yeah
depending on how you i think i think there's
plenty of people who there's like other people in
uh where are we going on the stage i have no idea
not the time nor the place to debate i've got him
i didn't mean to seriously bring up the topic of
capitalism i was more joking oh no no capitalism
in many ways has destroyed our our country in in
more ways than one but the planet yeah absolutely
uh but the concept of it you know like from the
small business owner days of america i think are
like the great times of capitalism that have now
ventured off into like corporate shenanigans that
have destroyed our world and our society yeah but
you know like i'm a fan of like the old ideals of
like yeah you know start your own business and and
be a small business owner or something like
that like those kind of things you know
start a business employ a few people
make something good you can give to the
world be self-employed yeah like there's
definitely uh things about or learning to
you know make investments in profit but then i
think there's a lot of the corruption there's
it's very obvious we really need to dive
into how it's been for the past few decades
alone of how there's been a lot of just complete
total corporations are people greg you know
there's there's got to be better ways
to to go about it you know there aren't
we won't see them in our lifetimes no it's
not american no and then you know if you yeah
anyway all right this is this is fun it's a weird
episode review a lot of great plots though i like
this episode a lot i can props like you said to
katherine han because i feel like i've been seeing
her for so many years and she especially is really
good at showing up playing the character being 100
committed and giving just what it needs without
ever feeling like she's trying to steal focus
and i always appreciate that about catherine
han which is why i'm so happy that in a post-wan
division world she is really getting her flowers
in recognition because i think she deserves that
[__] totally totally yeah man all right
guys well hey i think it's time to do a page
pandemic jones page i haven't checked the
list but i'm assuming you're still on there
i think he's on there pj was thinking about who
would i want to um be the father of my child
and it's definitely you it's definitely
yeah i think pandemic jones would make
a hell of a dad because he'd make it all about me
he'd find a way to give his sperm our way and
then being a pandemic jones i could finally
fulfill my master plan with that pj sperm where
my seed would his seed would spread under my name
throughout throughout the
world get a child of greg alba
it's pj sperm but under mine spreading under
my name then then everyone would because it's
like you would read the list of all the great
qualifications that pj has but he'd use my name
and be like but this is all technically you know
under that because it's capitalism so i would buy
pj's by the right i buy the right said pattern
is first i'd buy the rest played them worldwide
and then i would exploit it worldwide so that way
uh in every state where people have a child they
would always go wow this list is great of this
person and then before you know it there'd be a
little greg and but he's looking like pj though
but through legality titling it would be greg
everywhere across the world uh so pj i'm talking
about your sperm my own house yeah how do you
feel about that this only makes sense if you watch
the episode and if you ever threaten to leave the
patreon we're going to dump all of your reserve
sperms and then what will you do i'd swim in it
and then i'd be people come out of spare men
i just thought of several new pj acronyms
all right we'll see you guys soon